but not all people who can give birth  are women  you can call yourself whatever you want  if you have a patient who says i am a  woman giving birth hear me roar you can  tell her that you go girl if i was  um a person who could give birth but  didn't identify as a woman i would not  want to see you and i would not trust  you you know that's not much of a threat  i mean if i was an ob gyn or  you know if i if i if i worked in a  birthing center  and uh there's a man who claimed to be  pregnant and didn't want to hire me  didn't want to be me to be involved  i'm fine with that you know i'd be fine  with that because that man whatever he's  pregnant with it ain't a baby i know  that okay  that's a guy who went a little too heavy  over at chipotle or maybe he's  some sort of alien parasitic infestation  i don't know what it is but if he's a  man he's not pregnant whatever's about  to come out and wherever it's coming out  i don't want to be there for it